[Music]
you
council was seeking to give maximum
commercial benefit they can from there
fella here isn't a sufficient arranged
pin that comes about or that the name
that comes back from the truth
particular sponsor that comes back from
trust us not meeting here particular and
they'd seen we received the right to
decline these at the moment it's default
name the stadium why McCleary so if it's
the name councils both agreed to it's
just for the stadium itself this is the
leaned in the interior video so this is
a recommendation we did he feel about it
and this is a particular person sorry so
nominates okay all right the moves over
D nominating any discussion
Oh Pat will when we go away we could
come up with a short agreement that
would cover just to be really clear that
we're respecting where that name comes
from and that we will work with you to
come up with a suitable agreement is it
okay right okay so it's can you view the
discussion I'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to you then carry things Chris
I pay just anyone 47 so sorry yes yep so
that's why a little yeah samake kyoto is
Tonya hello dude this is a request from
Tonya sue to bring to my hotel committee
it's a report for information about
automation of the camera above flood
gates
the original origin of this report was
the high point River rehabilitation
working party which was disestablished
at the in the last council term they
last meeting in September for a motion
to look at the feasibility of the
automation of this floodgate it is a
Environment Canterbury asset but the
kuiper rehabilitation working party was
a joint you can WDC working camp working
party so we have brought this request to
the utilities and roading committee in
November last year where the decision
was made to request their feedback of
the Runanga on this proposal for
automation or the feasibility study at
least and also to request feedback from
Environment Canterbury as the asset
owner the problem behind the reason that
the floodgate has been proposed to be
modified to the time I see a totai gate
is that the they are increasing sale and
incursions coming up the kayo River
could be post-earthquake
or it could be from low flows and the
way mcaddy River in summertime from
abstraction potentially or other reasons
that are leading to that's a line we're
now coming up higher than it was pre
2010 environment came to be scientists
Adrian Meredith has been looking at this
phenomenon so the report details quite a
few implications of modifying that
floodgate to be a tide gate it's quite a
challenge
engineering because the flood gates only
use temporarily for floods
whereas Tiger it would be used for four
months a year and there would be
significant hydrological implica logical
impacts and cultural impacts which was
something that was hoping to seek the
feedback from from the Runanga as well
as social and yeah that's quite a
financial cost
so I'm happy to take any questions you
have and the the process that was
originally proposed back with this
report was written back in February was
initially to to discuss the process or
so forth or how we would signifi
but we proceeded by contracting to it's
helpful you go thank you
Christian yeah we you Superman we could
talk business
page 39
any other questions so we've got a
recommendation for ease is that the
front of the pages that helps someone so
pages 31 we see them
everyone yep so the recommendations but
actually the yeah yes to the double
summary helps clarify really write down
what is the real ass piece I think so
it's a report for information basically
just updating the process and yes it was
of a Chris from yourself and the I was
thinking potentially the feedback might
be back from the Runanga for this
meeting but I'm not sure if it's been
circulated or not by American attire I
believe it said it is be prepared to
move to moved by our secret by Google
any discussion
what do you think Pat because you know
this about beer than I do
some of those things you need the stuff
that off that are one of my office in
the office this afternoon
this is just this effectively is just
noting process so it's got to come back
so unless so you all hit me to follow
that yeah
then just sleep let us know through
Sophie that would be great okay so any
further comments put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to that carriage the next item
is just before we move to briefing us
just to confirm than our next meetings
to be we've already agreed so it's just
noting that that's Tuesday the 18th of
August and it'll be here the council
chambers rather than that okay so at
this point old guys and we'll move into
briefing
[Music]